[Música]
no se puede encontrar aquí
cuando llegue a hoy me acordé que yo y
aquí hace por lo menos 55 años aquí al
frente cuando no estaba esta avenida y
en una casa que mamá para defenderse
tomaba inquilinatos y hacendada pieza 9
motel sino familias entonces nos alcoba
vivíamos los cuatro hijos mamá la
muchacha y el revés pero porque hacíamos
la comida eso me trajo los de cuadros y
esto hace el patio de la casa donde se
veía
muchas gracias a felipe por la
invitación yo que les puedo contar todos
sabes mucho de visas además ustedes que
yo mismo yo lo que he hecho es trabajar
en la vida porque me gusta primero que
todo no ticas es lo que les gusta
tiene en cuenta que primer mba es en pie
que como nunca hubiera necesidad no sé
decirlo el primero se envía y fue quedas
huérfano a los diez años
nosotros somos unos desplazados de la
violencia en santander la violencia
política que esa es peor que la
guerrilla porque liberales y
conservadores se agarraban se perseguían
de todo y para para el líder político
del capitán hijo se casó a los 60 años
su único matrimonio con mamá quedará
telegrafista 23 años
ella los aquagest para bogotá llegamos
antes del 9 de abril y aquí estamos pero
el con compró unos cambios de smack vea
cuando que un día que acaban de la calle
100a y sembraba papel y tenía una donde
fabrica desarrolla en el 20 de julio yo
lo acompañaba pero murió a los 10 cuando
yo tenía 10 años el yate a 70 años y
murió y quedamos en la calle
en la calle porque habíamos gastado la
plata mamá había gastado la plata en la
clínica de papá y todo aunque para pato
unos veinte hijos en el pueblo en
diferentes señoras y a todos les dio la
educación ninguno apareció
es muy irresponsable con sus papás uno
no valoran y agradece lo que le dan a
uno
nunca apareció ni con la presión los
hijos y no tenemos ni para el cajón
entonces mamá una pariente mamá le
prestado para el cajón de terrazo de ahí
en adelante digo que es mi envidia
porque eso me obligó a salir a la calle
y solo al colegio a el tranvía sí
arreglármelas y monte en el negocio mía
y en la cuadra era el black booster de
la época me imagino que ustedes ya no
saben qué es el black booster donde
alquila películas producto seis meses
épocas no había black boxes tampoco y yo
tenía un montón de cuentos de superman
de pato donald y los cambiaba en la cuál
los alquilaba y empezaba a ganar plata
con el ciudad matinal y compraba medias
del pato donald cosas de esas y ahí
empecé y a los 14 años empecé a trabajar
de mensajero
en una fábrica de vestidos yo hacía las
vueltas me acuesto por la que andaba así
súper rápido parecía que tenía tu look
si eso andaba corriendo para todos
haciendo diligencias y cómo sería la
ciudad de todo
en la fábrica de vestidos que me desea
pulgar recha ya porque porque yo me
mandaban a un mandado y hasta que no
conseguía las cosas no volvían no
llegaba entonces hacía absolutamente
todo
luego me encendieron ya vendedor empecé
a estudiar bachillerato nocturno con
unos amigos y ahí jugaba billar más
estudiantes o sea morir y me consigue
una novia en un café yo tenía 17 años
esos cafés que tengan 15 o 20 mujeres
lindas con una pollera siento me casé
una novia divina con ojos verdes
imagínese uno sin consejos ni nada y
dejé de trabajar me fui a ir con ella
pues aquí al parque los periodistas
de día de día dos días por la noche
jugar ha brillado ha ganado una plática
y a los dos años salí y no si sigo aquí
del mismo garitero el café criterios que
ponen las bolas de billar de no café no
vuelvo yo lloraba por la vieja y no
volví pero no tiene que tomar de estos
sus mensajes uno tiene que tengo más
decisiones en la vida lo que es malo
dejarlo y eso yo eso todo eso me empezó
a preparar para el futuro si eso del
niño empezar de aquí las cuentos de
manejar la plata de no gastar más de lo
que no puede todas esas cosas o decirme
y esta enseñanza de esta novia es con
todo lo que yo ha viajado en el mundo
ustedes nunca me verán en bares de mala
muerte ni casas de citas ni nada
eso lo preparo para trabajar ya los 20
21 años ser administrados de almacén ya
no vivíamos en inquilinato y vamos aquí
a la primera parte estábamos aquí en la
calle 28 con carrera cuarta en una
esquina y el lado ese apartamento un
dedo pero ya estábamos independientes
a los 21 años al mes al de almacén y yo
me voy
porque ese bar dice porque si me quedo
aquí sigo he vendido toda la vida y no
hago nada
que no tenía para pagar el arriendo que
ya nos hemos pasado al santa fe st si
era buen vaso en esa época 700 pesos de
arriendo 30 pesos para comer diario
muchas veces me a pie cuando des
completar los 30 pesos
si me demoraba en pagar el arriendo
porque gastaba el trago y en otras cosas
y no se han echado del apartamento tema
llorando pobrecita yo llega entonces me
toca ha llegado 11 12 la noche que ha
estudiado mira para poder me ha costado
pero eso fue otro mensaje cuando yo
empecé a organizarme ya
invertir la plata en lo que es y todo me
acostumbré a pagar a tiempo todo desde
esa época yo pago todos mis arriendos el
25 el mes anterior
se organiza uno aprende a manejar todo
en la vida han sido los mensajes monté
un almacén de en un octavo piso 1
oficina de zapatos vendía zapatos en las
oficinas mi hermano menor me ayudaba
fijaba los zapatos así estilo turco no
pues tendría la cuenta ahí cuál
calculadora computador no nada de eso sí
y ahí seguí y donde había tomado el
apartamento una oficina de fincas raíz
al jefe entrenamientos dije montamos una
oficina de fincas raíz ya no yo no tengo
plata le yo tengo algo
se quería en un edificio de lizio está
en la cárcel está con calle décima dije
no es muy feo un edificio nuevo en la
carrera décima con calle 17 y fuimos
compramos los muebles en camacho son
dante fiado todo
si tengo ese escritorio porque cuando me
separé ahí y es lo único que quiero
llevarme es el escritor ya está la
fábrica de entradas
grande lindo
y monte la oficina de fincas la y nos
fue bastante bien en el año 68 me casé
sobre el 65 del 68 me casé me fui a
ayudar a la soledad y ahí en el segundo
piso hay una modista mayor con un señor
carlos gómez mejor y yo había montado
una hipoteca en la carrera 15 con 82
donde seamos lo passador de medidas
camisas le hacíamos las ropa alfonso
lópez me llegue el mejor sastre y tenga
una sociedad pero yo seguía en mi
oficina eficaz raíz y me dijo yo sé
hacer chaquetas de cuero
en sociedad con está muy viejito les
paga millones yo lo de plata y le de
plata y de algunas chaquetas y una
cazadora con bolsillos bolsillos con los
bolsillos grandes y un cinturón le fue
tan bien que compró el edificio
sí porque le di a las grandes tiendas
era muy buen sastre muy bueno para eso y
en el año 72 él estaba como enfermos me
llamó y me dijo oiga mario es que me voy
a cúcuta estoy enfermo entonces quiero
vender una tienda que monte solo cuerda
y en la calle 19 490
yo no tengo plata cal de términos en la
fia también estoy a mi hermano le lleva
ya si esa tienda estaba de socio en la
mitad no sabía dónde quedaba ni queda ni
nada y era puro artículos de recuerdo
empezamos a ir me di cuenta que lo que
conseguía en el mercado no me gustaba yo
quería otra cosa diferente de calidad el
diseño y las proporciones los colores
las cosas entonces montamos la fábrica
ésta estaba quebrada en cali compré el
40% se nota y en esa época me acuerdo
con como un 6 de febrero que fue cuando
me separé también porque me fui a
calidad es decir la fábrica y yo tomaba
trago todos los días teníamos un bar
aquel a 19 con alfonso lizarazo y me
salcedo solanas rumba impresionante tras
lógico todos los días llegaba
y mi señora cuando llegue este verano
pues no quiero hablar contigo la cena
por la noche yo no no ya y bueno me
quiero separar de ti qué pasa si estás
con alguien que le haya ido el día ante
dios menos de 24 horas y tú tienes una
baby es en el edificio percal es de eso
hace 40 años y todas nuestras al
edificio fiscales sé que queda en la 15
con 70 y pico si me dices que no me
quieres
no te quiero perfecto pero hacemos
separación de bienes
salvo en mi casa cuando esté todo el
gandhi sádico
y así fue porque si no cogemos la flota
ahí mismo y si ha pasado después
empiezan las amigas a decirle mire usted
muy bruta él tiene tiene que además el
abogado la diestro se vuelve una
pelotera hay que solucionar las cosas de
una vez decirle a la gente sí o no pero
de una vez hecha o me fui ayuda mamá
mamá pablos esto lleva con su mamá
pobrecita trabajar el ministerio de
comunicaciones vendiendo estampillas y
pablo sexto lo es listo el instituto de
crédito otras historias eran
apartamentos de 120 130 metros dúplex y
la gente que eran muy chiquitos y que
eso tan feo y que no sé que lo compramos
el apartamento 120 mil pesos 30 metros
de cuota inicial
1500 al mes el doble lo que pongamos de
aliento entonces me casé y me casé pero
no entregan el apartamento
yo dije hasta que no está la mamá la
gesta la ya y me casé - 15 mil pesos
entonces hacia la cama que el primero
que uno compra su catre ahí listo
a vivir casado
y así así me ha ido pasando cuando vino
la fábrica a bogotá
motel la tienda le extiende la carrera
15 calle 98 y verdad noto donde las
noches que verdad no estamos mal tienes
el gerente de emisoras monserrate quien
tomamos traigo todos los días en la
taberna vasca se oiga beni
habáname unas cuñas la tienda de la
esquina salsa mentar jazz rancho licores
abierto y honduras manuel sus pecados
eso no se puede y bueno solo panadería y
abrimos el viernes santo no habría nadie
en bogotá y eso fue la locura lo mismo
cuando un almacén de la 19 yo mire
cerramos a mediodía y vamos a la casa a
almorzar y toda la gente que salía
caminaba y los almacenes cerrados es
cuando pueden comprar que abramos las
tiendas
todo el mundo me decía está loco las
abrimos y vean hoy en día es jornada
continua lo mismo en un centro de
empezar y los domingos está loco hoy en
día esto en la junta de unicentro y
estoy luchando para que abramos hasta
las 12 de la noche porque los mejores
días son sábados de domingo entonces la
gente es cuando puede ir a comprar el
resto de las mujeres trabajan los
hombres trabajan no tienen tiempo y
nosotros estamos viendo si pongamos
haciendo las 24 horas pero somos muy
perezosos no invertimos nos arriesgamos
nos salimos adelante
seguimos con la transmisión la fábrica
ha habido un socio el gerente ha
manejado todo el año 81 82 estaba
quebrado otra vez y medios leyendo el
resto y me fui
lg listo y me fui para la fábrica a
manejarla desde esa época almuerzo todos
los días en la fábrica hermosa con una
pandilla chiquita el anciano pedazo de
carne no salía y empecé y así seguimos
en el año 86 87 con unos amigos de
cannes los convencí trajimos la marca
valley en suiza y hacíamos el zapato
como los suizos eso me sirvió montones
la tuvimos la franquicia diez años lleva
suiza dos o tres veces al año y con de
trabajar con sus suizos delicioso pero
estos amigos de mentes chiquitas
entonces en lugar de hacer producto fino
producto barato y resolvió en desde ese
adiós en el año 92 abrió una tiene el
trump la cee no adiós y me cogió una
época complicadísima la bolsa que ahora
y yo pensé que colombia el mejor país
del mundo que no haya otra calle matas
de café muebles colombianos mis
productos sean colores café y negro no
sabía las estaciones de edad el nombre
de la marroquinería era un genérico pues
lógico me fue mal para estuvimos tres o
cuatro años y se fue mi otro envié un 20
envié que me salió barato regrese a
colombia contrate unas oficinas de
publicidad aquí otra en madrid llega
españa y me dijeron pero una clase en el
camino de fábrica producto luego
accequible soy el nombre del fundador yo
no había querido hacerlo llamé a bogotá
y cambien los hábitos de marroquinería
de cuero land ya los cambiamos los
armarios hernández llega a la gente yo
no me llamo el mar mario hernández no
comprado no compró no compraba pero como
soy tengo sigue insistiendo con calidad
diseño diferenciación precio servicio y
ahí eso pasó y es la marca hoy en día
cumple 20 años si no fuera por eso no
estaríamos y
miren lo que había que dije hay que
crear una marca yo quiero competir con
las marcas europeas mire también lo que
pasó
fui presidente de mi gremio 16 años que
hicimos la primera feria de cuero y
habían por lo menos 200 y pico de
fábricas pero era productos regular un
producto de cuero baqueta para
exportación note la calidad yo les decía
hagamos calidad hagamos cosas y nunca se
hizo nosotros hicimos todo lo contrario
mejorar calidad en un país que no hay
materias primas que no hay mano de obra
que no hay absolutamente nada tras
reinventar nuestras materiales de afuera
preparar la gente diseño
asesores de todos y el sector de cuero
se acabó aquel adicionarían 20 almacenes
de cuerda en unicentro en la avenida
caracas con calle 57 detrás del acuerdo
eso se acabó porque quedan las grandes
marcas europeas que toda mujer quiere
tener un louis vuitton una marca un
gucci prada una cosa de esas o producto
muy barato de china
pero alguien que está haciendo lo que
estamos haciendo construcción de marca
de calidad y el sueño de ser como las
marcas europeas somos los únicos en
américa desde canadá hasta chile no hay
otro que sea está haciendo eso yo no sé
si se inteligente o de bruto pues que si
nadie lo hace algo pasa entonces pero
ahí seguimos y no estamos haciendo gozo
lo que me gusta de todos somos iguales
todas las gentes son iguales mis
empleados todos somos iguales pero no
somos iguales todos tenemos dos manos
dos pies dos ojos dos orejas pero no
pensamos igual ni venimos todo lo mismo
este a este mundo
tengo que mi dios nos da el pan se nos
manda como pan debajo del brazo uno es
con mantequilla otro con mantequilla
otro con jamón otro con queso con que lo
quiere usted lo construye
entonces tiene que construir su pan en
la vida como si en donde esto siendo
transparente se impunidad
si no hay humildad
no hay nada
o se siguen estudiando administración de
empresas o cosas hay postes un profesor
de harvard en eeuu que escribió un libro
y habla mucho de
organización las cosas los gerentes hay
un triángulo ahí el primero lo que es el
gerente número de uno del 12 13 el 4 y
el 5 que se necesita para llegar al 5
dentro de 1.400 empresarios en eeuu sólo
10 llegaron a eso que se meta aumentar
humildad no hay nada
las mujeres lindas todas las reinas
piensan que no se les va a descubrir las
cosas nada y la vejez y que no sean
arrugas después no se preparan para la
vida no ahorran para la vejez no esto y
mire cómo terminan lo mismo son las
empresas o la gente no piensa que como
ya tiene para comprar un carro amigos y
para mostrar lo que no tiene ya cogió el
cielo con las manos no eso no es así si
usted no está encima bien me preguntaba
por qué siempre está encima del negocio
mirando si uno no está mirando no sé qué
lleva el que lo siente que lo cosa todo
eso entonces tiene que estar manejando
todo con un director de orquesta si
todos los que están no está si tenga el
mejor pianista el mejor violinista todo
vaya vaya a la orquesta entonces esa es
otra enseñanza entonces lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahora y estamos nos hemos
arriesgado en el mundo sacamos colores
hace veintipico de años que la gente no
sacaba colores yo no los vendíamos yo
llamaba a las tiendas qué pasó con esos
once amarillo no lo hemos vendido al mar
yo no me importa que lo venda cuánta
gente pregunto y éramos muy gordos antes
de la apertura de la globalización de la
comunicación hoy en día la moda llega a
los 45 años
hoy en día llega al instante mire cómo
se dicen ustedes no todos ustedes miren
como el país avanzado mire como tenemos
las ciudades intermedias como hay
centros comerciales los supermercados
hoy en día vivimos mejor todos
pero nos quedamos
mi señor hasta que olga lucia dictó una
conferencia a mis empleados de yoga y
una conferencia que se inventó que no
hacemos sino quejarnos nunca vemos lo
que tenemos nunca agradecemos nada y nos
quejamos por todo y estamos en un país
maravilloso con dos mares con muchas
oportunidades 45 millones de habitantes
aspiracionales para estar mejorando la
clase media todo el año 1200 había un
millonario que te da 400 mil millones de
dólares
cinco veces más del señor de el señor de
microsoft pero el infeliz a la cabeza en
nueve aspirina
no había luz eran las velas por viaje
gastaba uno o dos años y todo se mide
todo lo que tenemos hoy en día
pero somos unos grandes beneficiados
pero tenemos que construir un país entre
todos tenemos que pagar impuestos
tenemos que ser ordenados no gastar más
de lo que tenemos guardadas para la
vejez
y construir familia y ser agradecidos
con uno mismo con la vida
es mi cuento contigo y chau
[Música]